salut romain ça bof qu'est ce qui
t'arrive accident de capotes pilule -
non non c'était hier enfin qu'après la
période du hyères du coup et ça ça
n'existe pas la pilule d'hier t'es
sérieux là de l'auto grand que ce n'est
pas toi qui doit prendre la pilule
ben oui oui oui la contraception c'est
un peu comme un parachute
la plupart du temps ça marche sans
problème tout se passe bien et on peut
profiter d'un moment plutôt sympa et
riche en sensations fortes
mais pour pouvoir en profiter pleinement
c'est bien de savoir que si par hasard
le parachute s'ouvre pas on en a un de
secours
en l'occurrence le parachute de secours
c'est ce qu'on appelle la contraception
d'urgence relance t'intéresse pas ce que
je raconte c'est pour les filles ah
d'accord
donc ça ne concerne pas le les rapports
sexuels non plus de nouveau à 6,6 oui
bien sûr et oui parce qu'on vrai ça
concerne tout le monde donc
écoutez bien oui donc la contraception
d'urgence c'est le parachute qu'on ouvre
quand le premier parachute ne sais pas
où vous pourrez pierre on ya recours
quand on a eu un rapport sexuel à risque
de grossesse c'est-à-dire un rapport
sexuel sans aucun moyen de contraception
ou avec un problème au niveau du moyen
de contraception utilisé comme un
préservatif qui craque
un oubli de pilule ou un problème de
timing quand on utilise la méthode du
retrait au passage des spermatozoïdes y
en a dans le liquide séminal vous savez
celui qui prévient pas trop quand il
sort l'a donc la méthode du retrait
en gros il ya deux possibilités se faire
poser un stérilet en cuivre en urgence
ou prendre la pilule andes
alors bon qu'on possède ou pas un vagin
et un utérus j'imagine que tout le monde
voit à peu près ce que ça donne
la pose d'un stérilet en urgence donc on
comprend vite que la deuxième option
c'est moins compliqué d'ailleurs de loin
c'est le moyen le plus utilisé
et pourtant dans ce domaine comme dans
pas mal d'autres on entend dire tout et
souvent n'importe quoi alors c'est parti
pour un petit point sur cette bullshit
sur la pilule on la pilule du lendemain
c'est que le lendemain alors non
l'expression pilule du lendemain c'est
un peu un double abus de langage d'abord
parce que non il n'ya pas besoin
d'attendre le lendemain
prenez-la dès que vous pouvez après un
rapport sexuel à risque de grossesse le
plus tôt serait le mieux ensuite parce
que ça marche encore le surlendemain en
fait selon le modèle de pilule on peut
la prendre jusqu'à trois voire cinq
jours après dans le doute posé la
question à un professionnel ça quand
même être de passer à côté à cause d'un
malentendu
la pilule du lendemain c'est cher
en france les mineurs à peuvent
l'obtenir anonymement gratuitement et
sans ordonnance en pharmacie
on peut l'obtenir aussi dans les mêmes
conditions auprès des infirmières
scolaires dans les collèges et les
lycées dans les centres de planification
ou d'éducation familiale et les services
médicaux dans les universités si on est
étudiant et qu'on soit bien d'accord
il n'y a aucune honte à la demande et
les sens d'en parler c'est la loi vous y
avez droit
dans tous les autres cas de figure vous
pouvez acheter la pilule du lendemain en
pharmacie même sans ordonnance et dans
ce cas là le prix varie entre 3 et 20
euros et si vous avez quand même une
ordonnance la sécu rembourse 65 entre la
pilule du lendemain c'est comme un
avortement alors non pas du tout parce
que l'idée c'est d'agir avant la
fécondation
c'est à dire d'empêcher la rencontre
entre un spermatozoïde et l'ovule et
éviter un truc qui a pas encore eu lieu
même chez les plus sains c'est pas un
avortement jamais la pilule du lendemain
ça rend stérile et non non plus en fait
voilà comment ça marche
la pilule du lendemain est modifié
l'action de l'hormone qui est
responsable de l'ovulation ce qui a pour
conséquence de retarder l'ovulation le
temps que les spermatozoïdes soit plus
assez en forme pour féconder l'ovule
c'est à dire pendant à peu près cinq
jours ouais ça se fatigue vite ces
petites bêtes là géré par guy môquet ne
peut pas y aller j'ai peur quand je vois
ce trou noir j'ai le coeur qui lâche
mais ça agit que ponctuellement sur le
cycle en cours
donc après tout rentre dans l'ordre pas
de problème de stérilité
oui mais c'est dangereux pour la santé
quand même non les effets secondaires
qui sont le plus souvent observés après
la prise de la pilule du lendemain
c'est les mêmes que ceux qui sont
associés aux cycles menstruels genre
nausées fatigue tension dans les seins
maux de ventre mal de tête saignements
dehors des règles etc
mais c'est pas à tous les coups toute
façon c'est temporaire d'ailleurs la
pilule du lendemain elle est
déconseillée on contre-indiqué
uniquement en cas d'allergie à un des
composants ou dans le cas de certaines
maladies
la pilule du lendemain c'est pour les
gens pas sérieux c'est tout le contraire
en fait prendre la pilule du lendemain
quand on a eu un problème de
contraception c'est super responsable je
vous rappelle que l'idée c'est juste
d'éviter une grossesse non désirée donc
servir à prendre la pilule mais
oui un peu avant un peu après on va pas
revenir là dessus on doit parler qui
serait pas sérieux et encore on n'est
pas là pour juger ce serait de dire oui
bon d'accord il ya un petit risque mais
on verra bien à et petite piqûre de
rappel pour avoir un rapport sexuel à
risque de grossesse faut être 2 minimum
quoi donc pour gérer la suite c'est
pareil on s'impose pas mais on se
propose au moins bien sûr voilà la
pilule du lendemain c'est un moyen de
contraception régulière a alors non je
rappelle que pilule du lendemain c'est
l'expression populaire pour
contraception d'urgence alors dans
contraception d'urgence c'est vrai il ya
contraception mais il ya urgence rifi
donc nous c'est une méthode de
rattrapage qui est pas efficace à 100%
et qui ne remplace pas un moyen de
contraception classique
d'abord parce que c'est pas fait pour ça
ensuite parce que ça ne protège que pour
le rapport sexuel qui a eu lieu avant la
prise de la pilule et pas après
d'ailleurs les jours suivants il faut se
protéger avec un préservatif jusqu'au
retour des règles et donc ça doit juste
être utilisés pour attraper un loupé un
étang je vous tiens enfin façon de
parler
la pilule du lendemain c'est comme la
pilule classique ça protège ni des
maladies ni des infections sexuellement
transmissibles
donc à moins d'avoir assuré le coup dans
les règles de l'art la base c'est le
préservatif voit la dtcc fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo d'ici là
protégez vous contre tout ce que vous
n'avez pas envie qui vous arrive
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]